nous assure qu'on est depuis hier ça
parce que non nous faisons nos habits
leurs prix spots parce que nous aurons
beaucoup plus d'argent alors je croyais
tout garder cette archive date de 1979
et quarante ans plus tard la pauvreté
des enfants existe toujours en france
pire elle a augmenté ces dernières
années combien yat-il d'enfants pauvres
en france un million selon l'insee et
autres pays compte aujourd'hui quasiment
2 million et demi d'enfants pauvres cris
des larmes de l'unicef sur la précarité
des enfants dans notre pays regardez 3
millions vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
les enfants premières victimes de la
précarisation de la société regardez
cette courbe
le taux de pauvreté des enfants est
toujours supérieur au taux de pauvreté
de la population dans son ensemble
conséquence pour ces enfants honte
sentiment d'exclusion
tout comme la jeune fille de 1979 cet
enfant de 2009 subissez les railleries
des camarades de classe et le roger
au début il avait beaucoup de copains et
quand ses copains venaient chez lui une
seule fois c'est fini le pot il devenait
plus le chercheur c'est fini et le
lendemain à l'école ce dernier se moquer
de lui en lui disant voilà en plus de
l'exclusion sociale
ces situations de précarité ont des
conséquences sur le développement de
l'enfant sa scolarisation par exemple un
constat déjà fait en 1979
ils ont d'énormes difficultés par
rapport aux autres enfants ses
difficultés elle démarre dès la petite
enfance à l'école maternelle c'est des
problèmes de langage d un vocabulaire
beaucoup plus pauvres que la moyenne des
enfants et ces difficultés vont aller en
s'accentuant mêmes difficultés pour ce
collégien un 2009 mustapha 13 ans tente
de faire ses devoirs sur une table
beaucoup trop petit
proposé à l'égalité des chances et le
mot d'ordre des différents gouvernements
successifs qui met en avant l'importance
de l'école mais dans son rapport l'oscd
indique que l'école ne parvient pas à
corriger les inégalités sociales
[Musique]